es ist okay wenn ich ein bisschen farbe
waren ich war die restliche strecke
du wirst doch schon den ganzen weg von
vater staat
leute die schon lange nicht mehr im kino
waren sollten da rein
denn der grund warum sie schon lange
nicht mehr im kino waren wird davon
kaputt gemacht das ist ein horrorfilm
und das ist ein science fiction film
aber er ragt aus dem was in zeiten wo
unter horrorfilm lob verstanden wird und
unter science fiction film transformers
verstanden wird mit allen ihren 7000
teilen die alle immer immer weniger gut
werden hier mehr es davon gibt
da ragt ebenso ein film tatsächlich wie
jemand anders über etwas anderes in
einem anderen zusammenhang einmal gesagt
hat eiffelturm hoch aus dem gemetzel
heraus ich will zurück
sie waren unsere familie einen tag und
eine nacht dann geht es sofort zurück
diese beiden brüder sind vor ungefähr
zehn jahren aus einer landkommune
geflohen
irgendwo der einöde ist da in der nähe
der wüste indianerreservat und so also
da wo es wird nichts zu holen gibt
und von dieser kommune sagt der ältere
bruder er habe den jüngeren dort
weggeholt weil das eine ufo sekte sei
die an konfusen scheißdreck glaubt und
sich irgendwann mal umbringen wird
kollektiv wasser für seine jungen bruder
verständlicherweise ich wollte jetzt
fahren sie aber zurück aus komplizierten
gründen und stellt sich raus ist ist
alles gar nicht so die sind gar nicht so
schlimm diese leute sondern viel viel
schlimmer noch einen trick sehen
darmstadt
tut mir den gefallen es ist ein neuer
da kommt
[Musik]
entspann dich
der film ist nicht sonderlich
kompliziert aber das komplizierte ist
darüber zu reden
denn wenn man beispielsweise sagt da
gibt es mehr als einen mond obwohl es
auf der erde spielt oder wenn man sagt
da gibt es ein seil an dem ziehen sie
das ist in der nacht festgemacht und
sonst gar nichts dann hört sich das ja
alles ein bisschen gaga an das liegt
aber einfach daran dass ein guter
unheimlicher film natürlich sachen
zeigen muss die man nicht sagen kann
dass die antwort auf dem grund des sees
liegt also werde ich
wissen sie auf den grund gehen die
antwort darauf
[Musik]
wirklich ist
also dass ihre nachkommen
das großartige an diesem film ist dass
er etwas macht wohl ich eigentlich immer
die flucht ergreifen nämlich ist ein
film über geschichten ist ein film
darüber warum wir filmen eigentlich
angst haben können also es geht darum
was ist ein ende das ist ein anfang
unter wie viel druck muss man leute
stellen mit zeigt dass sie nicht
begreifen damit sie einander endlich mal
anfangen die wahrheit zu sagen
die sich dann aber als doch nicht die
wahrheit raus stellt denn sie haben zwar
nicht gelogen haben aber nicht gewusst
was die wahl ist
es ist ein monster drastisch was ich
hab's gesehen hat versucht mich fast
schon eine ahnung groß
ich habe selten tatsächlich so
profitiert für mein konkretes mit leute
irgendwie auskommen müssen oder über
wahnsinn reden müssen was ja wenn man
mit leuten auskommen will täglich der
fall ist wie bei diesem ding ist das
überhaupt möglich
du willst wissen was da draußen ist dann
geh raus und suche ist